hello everyone uh my name is ahmad
awadallah i'm a senior principal
research manager here at microsoft
research i'm delighted to have donkey
chen seong han and jiang fing zhao join
me today in this discussion session
about efficiency and adaptability of
large scale ai model
thank you so much for joining us today
at the msr research summit everyone
so let's get started uh large and
pre-trained models wouldn't have the
impact we have now without scale
but scale also requires immense
resources from both the data and the
computational files making the models
generally not very efficient
so to kick off the discussion i'll pose
a questions and i'd appreciate if you
guys give like a quick uh one-line
introduction about yourself and your
thoughts about the questions so the
question is
in your opinion what are the most
important dimensions of efficiency that
you think the deep learning community
should invest in
let's start with donkey
sure yeah hi everyone uh i'm dancing i'm
an assistant professor at princeton
university so my main research field is
natural language processing and these
days i have been very interesting how to
make lv systems and or large scale
creation language models growing faster
and more efficient
so getting back to your question so i
think the first um very important
dimension in my opinion is actually data
efficiency so today we have a lot of the
large-scale protein models but these
models can still be used for many years
but still we will have lots of new tasks
and the new applications that we need to
solve and how can we actually
we cannot collect a large amount of
annotation examples for all these new
tasks it's not a sustainable solution so
i'm personally very excited by this
research direction of how to use prompts
to solve nlp problems and how can we
actually teach models to learn from the
instructions or even generalize on
between the different instructions
i think it's a very exciting promising
direction for me
and uh i'll just talk about another
important direction or dimension i think
very important is actually the
pre-training cost
so these days the
physical training is basically dominated
by um several like um major technology
called tech companies and it's basically
because um just training these models
are very expensive and it's based out of
the reach for most uh
academic academic research labs but
still i think there are a lot of people
who actually want to build their own
models
their own pre-trained models either for
specific domains such as like biomedical
domains or scientific documents or even
the current prediction models actually
can easily get outdated so how can we
actually trim on this patient models
from the scratch these are academic
projects i think a very very very
important direction that we want to
start in the future
thank you so much donkey uh so song do
you have anything to add
yeah hello everyone my name is
i'm assistant professor at mit we focus
on tiny ml and efficient deep learning
from hardware to the algorithms so we
feel for natural language processing
there is a huge redundancy in the
natural language therefore there are
there is a lot of opportunity to remove
those redundancies
uh for example uh in a sentence human
language can be highly inefficient right
language inefficient those two words
probably cover the whole meaning of this
sentence with five words right so there
is a huge opportunity to perform such
token level high level pruning well the
attention mechanism
pruning is fundamentally different from
conventional model compression
techniques like weight pruning since in
the attention mechanism there is no
weight so there is a lot of challenge
for
applying those conventional model
compression techniques to natural
language
recently another line of research came
for neural architecture research try to
search efficient architecture for
language language
tasks
however there is a study showing that
the evolved transformer basically the
neural architecture
evolved the transformer with neural
architecture research is taking as much
carbon footprint as five cars in their
whole lifetimes like six thousand
um six hundred thousand pounds of co2
emission so that's a lot of
uh
very badly for the environment therefore
uh it's very it's high time that we put
a lot of attention on this green ai
especially for nlp tasks
um and hopefully pave the way for this
tiny ml green ai to make uh these tanks
greener smarter faster and more
accessible to everyone
yeah absolutely thank you so much song
jumping
hi hi i'm jim van gaal i'm the
distinguished scientist of microsoft
research i i completely agree with
stenchy and the song and i also want to
point out that i strongly believe that
the
adaptive autonomy
or the ability of adapting itself in a
changing environment by continual
lighting
is the most important feature for future
ar systems yeah you know as we are
building hundreds of or even thousands
of new ai applications every week
it is prohibitively expensive to
maintain them all
and i also want to point out the recent
neuroscience research reviews that
actually human brains are remarkably
energy efficient and learning right but
many of these biological features such
as special temporal dynamics
that supports the adaptive flexibility
and the efficient learning of humans
have not been
yet translated into the design of this
neural language model systems
so i also believe that biologically
inspired deep learning is one of the
most promising research directions
thank you so much
jen feng and and dante and song both of
you mentioned something very interesting
about the
uh gains or the benefits that we get to
stand in to to gain stand to gain if we
actually invest in efficiency ranging
from increasing accessibility to
sustainability and and saving
environmental costs but there are so
many other things that we tend to gain
as well from economic costs
environmental cost increasing
accessibility agility of development so
efficiency is not becoming more on after
thought but it's actually a requirement
for next generation of large-scale ai
so i was uh thinking if you have any
thoughts about what risks
what what what are the risks that we
face if we don't invest in efficiency as
we think about building the next
generation of ai models
both from the developer perspective but
both from the environmental perspective
the end user perspective
yeah i'm still arguing that um
either pre-training and fine-tuning cost
for a lot of the academic researchers
would be a still very important problem
to address next
so these days we are getting bigger and
bigger language models
even like uh
if we cannot afford the cost to
trend these models or fine-tune these
language models how can we even have
access to them
to the this model for example gpu stream
model i think still like an unresolved
problem so there'll be something that we
can invest
next
great and song i think we lost you for a
second but like we have you back now we
were basically talking about the
uh what do we what do we stand to gain
by investing in efficiency and what do
we risk if we ignore efficiency as we
think about the next generation of large
ai models
yeah so we think we'd like to be
inclusive for different works of people
to benefit from ai and democratize it
and make a more accessible so for
example we may have people that have
high-end phones and people with low-end
phones we want to be inclusive for users
who have low low-end phones who have
less computation budget
right and be able to deploy it not only
on the cloud but also on the edge
devices to rather preserve the privacy
right so currently there is still a long
way a huge gap between what we have and
what we need so
especially also considering the
environmental issue that we definitely
don't want to
have a language model take as much
carbon footprint as much as five cars in
their whole lifetimes so think about the
whole global warming issue these are all
important factors if we risk not doing
such research
absolutely and jen think at microsoft we
think about this problem both from the
research side but also from the
practical side so you have any comments
on what what why does efficiency really
matter in practice
yeah first of all i think we really need
to make all these giant models more
accessible
to the wider audience including the
research labs from academic purpose if
they don't have
a large-scale gpu cluster they should be
still should be able to use these models
adapt this model to new tasks
i think first of all
we should make this model probably more
sparse and modular it's just like a
switching right
it's not necessary for each research lab
to build a big session in google search
when you're from scratch
but
take a look uh yeah look at what's
happening now
a lot of research drivers are able to
run experiments
based on these
large-scale search engines i think
sooner or later this giant language
model can be served in a similar manner
and that that i think that's the first
step
and fumble these big companies can do
not cannot do everything for uh for for
for the people right so they really need
to democratize in the whole process
so social engineering is a good example
i
would like to see what can be happening
in the future
yeah absolutely and i think this is also
related to a point you made earlier a
song about work on neural architecture
search and related to that the field has
been really dominated by
transformer-based models first in
language and now even making their way
into vision
uh so as you think about neural
architecture search and other
investments in improving and creating
the architectures of the future
such that they are inherently more
efficient and easier to adapt do you
think that should be a priority for the
research community to focus on
yeah so uh from we have from our prior
prior work we find those neural
architecture research
uh can be uh consistently output from
human outperforming human design so we
got a world record by used alibaba
adopting our ones for our model
achieving more than one million images
per second of influence speed on eight a
100 gpus on the titan on the aml perf
benchmark which is the olympic game
for ai chips uh so with the success in
the
vision side we feel it it's promising
also on the
natural language side
um and also but the key bottleneck is we
need to reduce the training cost the
search cost
rather than five cars entire lifetime of
carbon emission
so there are some existing work that's
showing very promising results such as
using the westfall approach and we apply
that to natural language as well which
is called the hardware aware transformer
basically reducing the search cost by a
large margin so even research labs in
schools like us can afford uh to search
a much better
machine translation model that's 2.7
times faster than the evolved
transformer so there's still opportunity
i think
great
and uh going back to uh the comment you
made earlier donci about data efficiency
and how it's very important for machine
learning we know that benchmarks have
been playing a major role in many of the
recent advances in deep learning what
are your thoughts on the current state
of benchmarks used for evaluating large
language models and how can we think
about the next generation of benchmark
that actually encourage creating more
efficient and adaptable models
yeah i think this is a very good
question and i also feel that the
current leaderboard and benchmarks do
not really address the computational or
efficiency side of the
lp models
um
and a few months like i've been working
on like a pruning and distillation kind
of work for nlp models in the past year
and i found it pretty hard to actually
compare the different types of published
work because they use different
hardwares they just report like let's
say let's prune x percent of the smart
the base and reach the um
accuracy why on someone's received
benchmarks but there isn't a way to
actually really compare all this
existing work you are very like a
unified benchmark or platform i think
that could be something that we can work
on so we can create a benchmark or plan
create a platform so everyone can
actually submit their models and we can
actually make a fair comparison so we
actually understand um really what it
does state art and dismantle research
absolutely and jen think do you have
anything to add here and especially not
just about bench market about what do we
need to do as a community generally for
moving forward
i agree with strange i think the the
many of the current leaderboards in some
sense are misleading because they they
assume aesthetic environment and assume
there are a lot of training data
and they only cared absolute performance
on specific tasks this is not how we use
these ai systems in the real world in
real world it's always dynamic and every
time you only receive a small amount of
data and you need to adapt your system
very very quickly so i think if we
shift the folks from
you know
data hungry model training styles
to
a fast adapting environment we will have
the academic to to to to focus on the
really important
research problems for all of us for this
i think we we need to build new
uh new data sets new benchmarks that
really simulate the real world
situations i think
bumper in this msr summit there are
several talks
uh
on uh new benchmarks
okay
yeah so thank you so much uh don chi
sanga and jen think for the lively
discussion there are many more questions
that i wanted to ask but unfortunately
we ran out of time for this session
so thank you so much again for joining
us for the discussion as well as for the
research summit and thanks everyone who
is listening in for joining us and hope
you will enjoy uh the next session of
the deep learning and large scale ai
track as well as the rest of the summit
thank you so much everyone
thank you thank you